- All right y'all we've
reached the end of the hour,
but good news,
sometimes I save the best for last.
This is, what I'm liking.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Over the last couple of years
we've all needed little boosts of humor
and inspiration to get us through the day.
An animator known as Coolman Coffeedan.
Specializes in this.
Maybe you've seen his work before.
It's so cute.
His simple hand-drawn
animations have racked up
hundreds of millions of views.
They're typically super sweet and silly
with upbeat messages.
Take a look.
- Hey, you wanna see a magic trick?
I'm gonna make something
amazing... pop out of thin air.
(beeping noises)
(grunting)
(laughs)
Yeah.
It's a mirror...
because you're the one that's amazing.
And you need to remember that.
(audience clapping)
- Aww, he's so adorable.
He's also an author, his new book,
Ur Special: Advice for Humans.
Is out now.
Let's get Coolman Coffeedan in here.
What's up Dan?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- What's up Kelly?
How's it going?
Thanks for having me on.
This is awesome.
- No, thank you for joining us.
So this all started by accident, right?
- Totally by accident.
I was always that kid in school,
doodling on my homework and my notes.
I was that kid,
you know, and people like that.
My friends around me kind
of fell in love with these
characters that I would
doodle on my notes.
And it wasn't until this
random summer night in 2017,
when I had this three in the morning idea.
I didn't really know how to animate.
I sketched it real
quick, and I went to bed.
Didn't think much of it.
And that video ended up
being my video called,
snakes have legs,
which has gone on to be one of
the most viral hits to date.
Hundreds of millions of
views around the world.
And I was like, okay, cool.
That works.
My animation resonated with people.
And a few years later,
here we are with my book.
It's pretty cool.
- That is super cool, that
you're doing something you love
and it worked out.
That's awesome.
And they're simple animations,
but they have a real impact.
So what kind of feedback do
you get back from people?
- So the messages I get from
people are super heartwarming.
I was at Starbucks a few weeks ago
and the barista was a fan of my work.
And she was telling me how
at the start of the pandemic,
she would send these videos,
my videos back and forth with
her little, little sister,
because they were so like, anxiety calming
and like told you
everything was gonna be okay
during such a questionable time.
And that's what my videos do,
for so many people around the world.
This just remind you that,
"Hey, you're special."
"You're loved."
"You're not nearly as ugly
as you may think you are."
And it's a source of
positivity for so many people.
And this is a dream come true.
I've always wanted to
do something like this.
- All right.
Be sure to pick up
Coolman Coffeedan's book.
Ur Special: Advice for Humans.
Thank you so much.
Coolman Coffeedan.
(audience clapping)
I'm liking your posts right now.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Coolman Coffedan]
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen.
Makers of Frixion.
The go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you my man.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- No way...
Thank you so much.
What?
That's crazy.
Kelly, thank you.
That's incredible.
- [Kelly] Well, thank you so much.